Hey everybody, it's Charlie new flash costume.
So let's go crazy about this.
You may have noticed a little while ago grant
Gustin said it's about time Barry gets a new
costume just teasing the idea that he would
get some new version of his flash costume
you actually already seen them in a bunch
of different versions of the costume since
the show started, so I'll explain what's going
on with this all the coolest versions of the
costume from the TV show and the comics and
the stuff that they might be able to do in
the future it's one in a long line of really
awesome Super Bowl weekend trailers and teasers
that are dropping.
I'm doing a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the flash on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
What's going on the actor who played Wally
West was teasing that he was getting a new
costume a while ago so every season.
Even within each season.
They tweak the costume just a little bit even
if you can't visibly tell the are is actually
a couple different versions that he wears
depending on the types of scenes that they
film there's one version he wears when the
mask is fully on is a harder version.
So it doesn't move around when he turns his
head.
But then when he's filming other scenes with
the Cal off when he just walking around with
it.
It's a different version is a little bit softer
that sort of folds on itself the horn version
is almost like a leather helmet.
But, since season one there's been a couple
different versions of Barry's costume.
So far the first version was in the pilot,
it was this really hard costume again grant
Gustin these crazy headaches, so they had
to make a better version of the first version
of the suit.
So outwardly it looked the same but it was
a lot more modular there were different pieces
and always yes you saw this picture from from
behind the scenes he always doesn't where
the emblem until he walks on set a lot of
people saw this.
And because of the Eddie episode there like
oh, maybe it's gonna be a flashback it will
be the old version of the emblem, but even
if that's true he still walks around when
he's in his flash costume without the emblem
on they don't attach it to the get ready to
do scenes because he zips the suit of the
front it's almost like a jacket now.
So over the course of season one in season
two the suit itself's got a lot more comfortable
for him to wear.
So when it came time to make Wally suit they
kind of did the same thing, so I'm guessing
the suit that we saw him at the beginning
of the season.
The Wally suit is actually changing just to
get a little more comfortable you see that
Wally is a slightly different haircut in the
behind-the-scenes pictures.
So I think you look a little bit cooler that
he will be able to tell the difference unless
you're really paying attention closely, it's
the same basic suit, the biggest color change
was at the end a flash season one when I fought
her/a Christmas he said that fighting for
centuries to can't really think that this
is the future that would mean Dr. Wells whoever
he is also from the future have to say really
taken the brighter red suit the white on the
simple so wait a second.
Suppose we now change the color on your suit
will it be because we got the idea from this
picture that would mean were living in a causal
nexus is why this is so trippy like Marty
in the Polaroid Cisco as the burning question
do we make that white emblem because we saw
in the future or were we always destined to
make it come to season two they actually make
the white emblem and then they start making
upgrades to the actual tech of the suit he
fights Captain cold.
They have a version of the emblem that will
heat up so Cisco tweaks that technology based
on the types of bosses that Barry goes up
against.
So there been all kinds of teasers about future
versions of the costume.
There have been many different versions in
the comics so the idea is is that will eventually
see a future version of Barry and a crazier
more hardcore version of the suit.
Now I'm not talking about flash movie suit
like the injustice looking version of the
suit.
I'm talking about of Barry that's more full
of speed force may be the blue version of
the costume or something close to it.
Just to let us know that he's become this
crazy being.
So we might not actually get to see that the
season but we might get teasers for it later
on I'm not expecting him to wear anything
but the red version of the costume on most
of the show.
The closest WTF color change that I actually
think that will see this season is a future
vision of Wally wearing the red costume in
a time.
When Barry has died and gone away and he's
become the main version of the flash.
I think on one of the TV shows will see a
future vision of that but on the main show.
It will always be Barry and Wally in their
respective costumes, so just remember the
grant Gustin is the main actor on the flash
the not can it kill them off he's not going
to go away he'll still be there.
They signed seven your contracts, but there
might be episodes when he gets stuck somewhere
and Wally has to step up the gorilla city
episode is coming the be a really cool Wally
Iris team up while everybody else is dealing
with the gorilla city stuff.
That's the kind of stuff I'm talking about
the new version of the Cal that he's having
made right here is probably just a more hardcore
version of his red costume.
So in the comics you may have seen the blue
costume that belongs to the new 52 future
version of Barry Allen from 20 years in the
future from this post-apocalyptic timeline
were all this craziness is happened Wally
has died.
He hasn't been able to save all the ones that
he's loved and he blames himself for creating
all these cracks in the speed force, so the
only solution you can come up with is to go
back and kill himself in the past.
So the new 52 flash costume looks a little
bit different little bit shinier I was in
a big fan of it the blue costume was really
cool though it was another blue costume during
the war of light that Barry wore when he was
a blue lantern that was a more cloth looking
version slightly less hardcore but still very
cool because he had the lantern ring that
something that we can dream about but the
probably never be able to do on the TV.
Shows the war of light where everybody gets
a lantern rings the most hardcore version
of the flash costume that we could ever possibly
see is the God of death speedster.
So Barry Allen during Darkseid war in the
comics gets merged with the black racer by
the anti-monitor and he becomes the new god
of death which drives him a little mad Batman
became the God of knowledge.
Sitting on the Mobius cheer they all went
a little nuts all the Justice league members
when little crazy the fun thing about that
is that the TV show can always play with ideas
like that like savitar almost looks like a
version of that flash just this crazy God
of speed God of death.
But one of the reasons why I think that the
flash TV show won't actually put Barry in
one of those costumes is mostly because it's
a little too crazy for people that don't read
comics and just tune in week to week without
really understanding what's happening.
So if he showed up one day in the God of death
costume people would be like I don't understand
what's happening where's the flash the flash
is in a red costume, which I know sounds infuriating
because if you read comics you want to see
the really cool, comic book stuff.
So, they always try to find really fun ways
to make those Easter eggs are show you visions
of that in the future but then at the end
of the day take things back to normal.
The when they show up in the next episode.
Everybody's back to square one.
So whatever ends up happening at the end of
the season when we pick up next season will
be slightly different versions of the costume
physically the be a little more comfortable,
but the still be the yellow and red costumes
and the other like smaller reason for them
making a bunch of different versions of the
costume during the season is because they
trash a lot of them.
So every once in a while.
They do have to make a new one, but let me
know what is your favorite version of the
flash costume in which one do you hope makes
it onto the show.
I know everybody wants to see a version of
the blue costume I'm guessing that you probably
read the new 52.
Run the just so that really hard-core Barry
Allen.
It does look really cool and Barry Allen is
slowly filling himself and Wally with speed
force, so we might get white lightning Barry
in white lightning Wally pretty soon but if
you're ever frustrated by the TV show just
remember that they try to balance things so
that they can get too powerful.
Otherwise, there's no threats.
So there's always some way if they get really
powerful for them to take it back at the end
of the day that Barry got superpowerful with
the tachyons than the surprised twist is that
zoom did something that Barry couldn't prevent
using his speed.
So we end up having to give it to him going
back to square one.
So it'll be interesting to see how they solve
the problem of's savitar without making Barry
or Wally overpowered going into season for,
but don't forget undoing special giveaways
for the Super Bowl trailer so I'll add links
for that at the end of this it's gonna be
great can be crazy this weekend, there's even
some stranger thing season to the supposed
to drop tomorrow so I'll try to do is many
of those videos as I can while you wait for
that to post you can click here for the new
Logan trailer and you can click here for this
week's flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
the next video!